[Musique]
ouverte le 15 octobre c'est une clinique
réservé aux patients qui ont des
symptômes apparentés à l'aco vide soit à
ma gauche pour l'évaluation médicale qui
est fait avec des médecins des
infirmières ou soit dans corridor de
hama droit qui est la raison pour le
dépistage de la cave et 19 une clinique
en apparence presque semblable aux
autres et des environnements pour pour
examiner les patients les appareils et
fera donc pour procéder à l'évaluation
médicale complète mais on remarque qu
ici le personnel porte l'équipement de
protection intégrale contre les
infections
c'est vraiment contrôler toute la
journée ils en changent dans un
vestiaire qui dédiez avant les repas
aussi tous les tous les éléments sont
surveillés la direction pense que nos
anges gardiens seront mieux protégés que
lors de la première vague
y'a pas de quoi les employés à trappes
soudain mise à jour et chaque salle
d'examen est entièrement désinfecté
après chaque patient
l'instrument médicaux avec les légères
pour paul et les avis mais chassez
travers de la santé ou l'éducation
allez merci et ça c'est les prix
opérations en cas de doute les patients
symptomatiques vont deux côtés pour le
test de dépistage
il n'y a pas de table d'examen la
personne va s'asseoir va avoir sonné sur
le dépistage ce type de clinique est le
paratonnerre du réseau avec pour mandat
d'intercepter et de traiter des patients
infectés pour éviter des éclosions de co
vide dans les hôpitaux
ça va remplacer les cliniques digère pas
ce que tous les gens qui vont en voir
des symptômes du tout les grilles vont
venir ici
pour l'instant ces cliniques pour
patients symptomatiques semble jouer
leur rôle
les urgences ne sont pas plus occupé
qu'à pareille date l'an dernier et les
éclosions dans les hôpitaux restent pour
l'instant plutôt rare ici david
gentilles radio canada montréal